Koby and Vanessa Bryant's 20-year love
story may not have been perfect but it
was one for the books we met actually a
video shoot that I was filming she was
there and we actually had when we first
met we have it on tape the year was 1999
Vanessa was only 17 and still in high
school
Kobe was 20 got a point so she turns
around
I said scuse me when she named Vanessa
you know she my eyes got real big just
like wasting no time the two went on to
their first date to Disney Land a date
he replicated 20 years later in 2019
I've just been lucky a couple got
engaged after just six months announcing
the news at Vanessa's 18th birthday
party I'm so excited I get to rings this
year to ring up its rings Sabrina on
April 18th 2001 Kobe and Vanessa tied
the knot in Dana Point California the
people that we work with good excellent
job keeping everything quiet we had a
peaceful peaceful ceremony only about 12
people were at the intimate ceremony
doesn't sound better to mrs. Bryant Oh
on January 19th 2003 Kobe and Vanessa
welcomed their first child together we
have a beautiful baby girl my name is
Natalia diamante Bryant and you know
she's just she's amazing after suffering
a miscarriage in early 2005 the couple
went on to welcome their second child
daughter Gianna Maria better known as
Gigi on May 1st 2006 how great is it
having the two now how did it change
from one to two well I think it's time
management I think it's time is we got
to be able to balance the two you know
and but it's fun that we have a blast
in 2011 the then mom of two filed for
divorce citing irreconcilable
differences
but by 2013 the divorce was called off
no matter what personal issues Kobe and
Vanessa may have had they remained 100%
committed to their family what we try to
do is this just be who we are
love each other love our family and it's
keep one foot in front of the other keep
moving vanessa was excited for their
next chapter when Kobe announced he was
retiring from the NBA in November 2015
we related Vanessa's competitive
uncompetitive it's only natural that I
kids in the same ways and the lovebirds
went on to have two more daughters
Bianca was born on December 5th 2016 you
have three girls this will be your
fourth daughter and their youngest Capri
Kobe arrived on July 21st 2019 were you
hoping for a boy or I'm super excited I
love my princesses Kobe and Vanessa
appeared more in love than ever
following their reconciliation
On January 8th 2020 just weeks before
Kobe and the couple's 13 year-old
daughter Gianna died in a helicopter
crash along with seven others the black
mamba had this to say about his 20-year
relationship with Vanessa on the oldest
smoke podcast we forgot the secret sauce
man just commitment and competitiveness
of we are going to succeed this is a
constant up and down that have been
flows of relationships but that's also
the beauty of it and having a
persistence in the determination that
work through things very very tough
things we've been able to do that their
love was tragically cut short on January
26th and Vanessa has been mourning her
beloved husband and second child ever
since on Valentine's Day the 37 year old
posted a sweet photo with Kobe writing
in the caption quote to my forever
Valentine I love you so much missing you
so much on your favorite holiday
[Music]
you